don't it always seem to go that you
don't know what you've got till it's
gone when joni mitchell said she'd stand
in solidarity with fellow music great
neil young it upped the stakes for the
world's biggest streaming service
on wednesday spotify did as young
demanded and removed his songs from the
platform
now mitchell wants the same
i've decided to move all my music from
spotify she wrote on her website
irresponsible people are spreading lies
that are costing people their lives
the issue for both singers is
misinformation about coronavirus it
prompted neil young to make spotify an
ultimatum to drop controversial
podcaster joe rogan from the platform or
remove his songs i'm not i'm not an
anti-vaxx person right in fact i said i
believe they're safe and i encourage
many people to take them my parents were
vaccinated i just said i don't think
that if you're a young healthy person
that you need it the thing is rogan is
big business joni mitchell's hit big
yellow taxi has been streamed 135
million times on spotify but the joe
rogan experience is the platform's most
popular podcast and with its reported 11
million downloads per episode it's a
serious money spinner
but few artists are in a position to
take the financial hit that two singers
in their seventies are prepared to take
neil and joni are speaking from a
position of huge um
a privilege and they know that and
they're using their power to make a
comment but you know most
young artists feel
that they can't speak up against spotify
in fact they're afraid that if they do
they won't get playlisting or editorial
coverage and which might be the
difference between them playing to 10
people in a club or paying to 100 people
in a club spotify has said its policy
was to remove misleading content and 20
000 podcast episodes relating to covert
19 have been taken down
but rogan's remains and fact checker tom
phillips doesn't doubt how influential
he is he has a huge listenership and his
fans really care about what he says and
the kind of guests he invites on part of
the reason for his success is that he
takes the time to go into areas that
other people maybe aren't and so the
fact that he's doing this with covid and
with potentially covered misinformation
means that it's a huge potential vector
for seeding
misleading ideas in a wide
swathe of the public
spotify is yet to respond to joni
mitchell's decision
but neil young will be hoping other
artists are planning to follow suit
emma birchley sky news